Tom Hiddleston breaking a silence on
Taylor Swift then get me in trouble
you guys I'm Katie Kraus and if you're
wondering if that whirlwind romance was
real tom says quote of course you got
that 35 year old smoldering and suited
up in the March issue of GQ and he is
nothing but nice things to say about
Taylor quote she's an amazing woman
she's generous and kind and lovely and
we had the best time
the pair's split in September after just
three months and speculation about the
break-up ran rampant here's what he says
quote I only know the woman I met she's
incredible a relationship in the
limelight takes work and it's not just
the limelight it's everything else
Keller didn't want to come hang no just
here on my own buddy as for in this pic
of Tom wearing an I hearts yes tank top
on fourth of July the actor says he
slipped hurt his back and wanted to
protect the scratch from the Sun a
friend handed him the shirt to be funny
well it was a joke among friends Tom
explains the pair's globetrotting to
quote we decided to travel you have to
fight for love you can't live in fear of
what people might say alright you guys I
want to know what you thought of Tom's
interview about Taylor let me know over
on Twitter I'm Katie underscore cress
and I will see you next time
[Music]